let's see if we can apply what we've
learned to a particularly hairy problem
that I have constructed so let's say let
me see how I can construct this okay so
let's say in parallel I have this
resistor up here and I try to make it to
the numbers work out reasonably neat
that is for ohms then I have another
resistor right here that is 8 ohms then
I have another resistor right here that
is 16 ohms and then I have another
resistor here it's ohms actually I'm now
making it up on the fly I think the
numbers might work out ok 16 ohms let's
say that now here in series I have a
resistor that is let's say it is 1 ohm
and then in parallel to this whole thing
now you can see how hairy it's getting I
have a resistor that is I don't know
let's say 3 ohms 3 ohms and let's say I
have a resistor here
I don't let's just make it simple 1 ohm
and I know just to make the numbers
reasonably easy
I am doing this on the fly now that's
the positive terminal negative terminal
let's say that the voltage difference is
I don't know 20 volts so what I want us
to do is figure out what is the current
flowing through the wire at that point
right now for obviously that's going to
be different than the current at that
point that point that point that point
all of these different points but it's
going to be the same as a current
flowing at this point so what is I so
the easiest way to do this is try to
figure out the equivalent resistance
because once we know the equivalent
resistance of this big hairball then we
can just use Ohm's law and be done
so first of all let's just start at we I
could argue the simplest part let's see
if we could figure out the equivalent
resistance of these four resistors in
parallel well we know that that
resistance is going to be equal to 1
over 4 plus 1 over 8 plus 1 over 16 plus
1 over 16 so that resistance now it's
just adding fractions over 16 1 over 4
is 4 over 16 plus 2 over 16 plus 1 plus
1 so 1 over r is equal to 4 plus 2 is
equal to 8 over 16 the numbers are
working out is equal to 1/2 so that
equivalent resistance is 2 so that
quickly we just said well all of these
resistors combined is equal to 2 ohms so
let me erase that and simplify our
drawing simplify it so that whole thing
that whole thing could now be simplified
as 2 ohms
let me draw I lost some wire here don't
want to open want to make sure the
circuit can still flow so that easily I
turn that big hairy mess into something
that is a lot less hairy well what is
the equivalent resistance of this
resistor and this resistor well they're
in series and series resistors they just
add up together right so the combined
resistance of this 2 ohm resistor and
this 1 ohm resistor is just a 3 ohm
resistor so let's erase and simplify so
then we get that combined resistor right
we had a 1 we had a the 2 ohm that we
had simplified and we had a 1 ohm and
whoops I'm using the wrong color so we
had a 2 ohm in a wall mode on the series
of those simplify to 3 ohms well now
this is getting really simple so what do
what do these two resistors simplify to
well 1 over
their combined resistance is equal to
one over three plus one over three it
equals what two over three one over R is
equal to two over three so R is equal to
three halves or I don't know we could
say 1.5 right so let's erase that and
simplify simplify our drawing so this
whole mess this this the combined the R
is it a three ohm resistor and probably
another three ohm resistor is equal to
one resistor with a 1.5 resistance and
then and and actually this is actually
good point to give you a little
intuition right because even though
these are three ohm resistors we have
two of them so it's kind of giving it
you're kind of increasing the pipe that
the electrons can go in by a factor of
two right so it's actually decreasing
the resistance it's giving more avenues
for the electrons to go through actually
they're going to be going in that
direction and that's why the combined
resistance of both of these in parallel
is actually half of either one of these
resistance I encourage you to think
about that some more give you some
intuition of what's actually going on
with the electron although I'll do a
whole video on resistivity
okay so let's we said those two
resistors combined I wanted to lead all
of that those two resistors combined
equal to 1.5 ohm resistor that's one
point five ohms and now all we're left
with is two resistors in parallel so the
whole circuit becomes this which is the
very basic one this is a resistor 1
point 5 ohms 1 ohm in series did I say
perilous now no they're in series 1
point 5 plus 1 that's 2 point 5 ohms 2
point 5 ohms the voltage is 20 volts
across them so what is the current Ohm's
law V is equal to I R voltage is 20 is
equal to current times R equivalent
resistance times 2 point 5 ohms or
another way to write 2.5 is 5 halves
all right so 20 is equal to I times 5
halves or I is equal to
two fifths times 20 and what is that 2/5
is equal to I is equal to 8 8 and peers
that was not so bad I don't think
although when you saw it initially it
probably looked extremely intimidating
anyway if you understood that you can
actually solve fairly complicated
circuit problems I will see you in
future videos